IN OUR THIRTIETH AND WE ARE
GOING TO CALL THE MEETING TO
ORDER.
A WELCOME MEMBERS.
AND A I AM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SHARON QUIRK SILVA CHAIRING THE
JEDI HEARING --
WE DO HAVE ONE BILL ON FILE
WHICH HAPPENS TO BE MY BILL A.
B. SEVEN SIX SEVEN SO WE ARE
GOING.
TO GO AHEAD AND CAN WE TAKE THE
ROLE AT THIS POINT OUR WAY WE
DON'T HAVE YOU DON'T PART OF IT
WE'LL JUST GO AHEAD AND START AS
A SUB COMMITTEE.
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM COMMENSAL
TAKE THE ROLE AND THEN.
WE'LL HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STEINORTH [inaudible]
TAKE OVER.
CHAIR QUIRK SILVA.
HERE JERK WORKS OVER HERE
MEISTER ALLEN BERMAN CERVANTES
[inaudible]
CERVANTES HERE.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ HERE STEINORTH.
STEINORTH HERE VENOM CHAIR WE OF
COURSE
.
MADAM CHAIR WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
ALRIGHT SO WE ARE PRESENTING AB
SEVEN SIX SEVEN THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS LICENSE CENTER CONCUR
UP.
BILL AND THIS ACTUALLY HAS COME
OUT OF MANY MEETINGS THAT WE'VE
HELD IN OUR DISTRICT WITH
STAKEHOLDERS UP WHO.
REALLY WANT A THE AYE.
UPDATED VERSION OF HOW THEY CAN
ACCESS ON EVERYTHING RELATED TO
REGULATIONS FOR BUSINESSES.
AND DOES THIS IS BEEN LONG GOING
AS FAR IS AS WORKING WITH GO
BIDS TO PRESENT A IN A AGAIN IT
FIRST WAS GOING TO BE AN APP BUT
NOW IT'S WORKING ON A WAY TO
MAKE SURE THAT.
SOME OF OUR MILLENNIALS CAN UP
GO RIGHT ON TO THEIR PHONES AND
GET ONTO THE PLATFORM IN THAT AT
ALL LINES SO I IT LOVER.
AB SEVEN SIX SEVEN LEVERAGES AN
EXISTING GOBIZ WEB BASED
PLATFORM TO BECOME A MORE
POWERFUL SIGNAL ACCESS POINT FOR
THE STATE.
ECONOMIC AND BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS DELETE THE
REQUIREMENT TO ESTABLISH A NEW
MASTER BUSINESS LAW.
LICENSE CENTER AND INSTEAD
EXPAND GOBIZ GOBIZ IS EXISTING
ONLINE PROGRAM PROGRAM CAPACITY.
EXCELLENT THROUGH ANY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
SING NINER ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND TO
WE HAVE ANY.
QUESTION FROM THE PANEL.
MADAM CHAIR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE JUST WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THE CLERK WOULD YOU TAKE THE
ROLE.
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB SEVEN SIXTY
SEVEN THE MOTION IS WITH
RECOMMENDATION THAT SENATE
AMENDMENTS BEACON CURTAIN.
CHAIR QUIRK SILVA AYE AYE CHAIR
QUIRK SILVA AYE VICE CHAIR ALLEN.
BERMAN CERVANTES.
CERVANTES AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER
RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ AYE STEINORTH AYE
STEINORTH AYE.
EXCEPT WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR FIVE MORE MINUTES FOR OTHERS
TO ADD ON AND I'M JUST GONNA DO
THIS FOR FUN.
MY ONLY ATTEMPTING ONLY TRY.
AND I DID RIGHT.
GET AXED THOUSAND OUT AT WITH
SOLID
.
OPENING UP THE ROLE.
ITEM NUMBER ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
SIXTY SEVEN THE MOTION IS WITH
RECOMMENDATION THAT SENATE
AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED IN.
FIGHTER ALLEN BERMAN GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE.
THANK YOU MEMBER.
AND THAT CONCLUDES OUR HEARING
TODAY.
BILL IS OUT